gently  awkward on Tuesdays America's Got Talent  a passion and intimacy expert hit the  stage for a kissing demonstration and  Nick Cannon became the experiments  volunteer thanks to Howard Stern I know  if someone who recently became single  I'm going to nominate Nick I appreciate  you thinking of me Howard but I don't  need any help in this you probably do  you just don't know it you are divorced  somebody didn't like the way you were  kid  ouch Howard was a good wingman for Nick  though picking out a pretty test subject  from the audience think I found someone  you're gonna hate her and that's when  things got a little weird would you guys  be willing to have your first kiss as  part of a kissing lesson gently  Canon's kiss did it make the cut but now  it's on the internet forever so there's  that see that that's lusciousness right  there  you